يبدو ان منع النساء من الالتحاق بالجامعات
من قبل طالبان ليس النهايه الحظر شمل عملا
النساء في المنظمات غير الحكوميه وفي
وسائل الاعلام
والمشاركه هاتفيه ببرامج الاذاعه
والتلفزيون مع منع الموسيقى وحظر استخدام
الصالات الرياضيه والمتنزهات قوائم ومنع
اثارت غضبا بين الافغان والمجتمع الدولي
واحداثه انقسامات داخل طالبات مراسيم
المنع تلك صدرت بامر من الزعيم الاعلى
للجماعه هبه الله اخو زادته الذي يحكم من
مدينه قندهار جنوبيه افغانستان لكن مجموعه
من قاده طالبان تقاوم على راسهم الملا عبد
الغني برادر نائب رئيس الوزراء للشؤون
الاقتصاديه والثاني اقوى رجل بعد زعيم
الحركه بالاضافه الى وزير الدفاع الملا
يعقوب مجاهد
مؤسس الجماعه المله محمد عمر
ووزير الداخليه سراج الدين حقاني زعيم
شبكه حقاني في ما انتهت محاولتهم للقاء
زعيم طالبان لمناقشه حظر النساء من
التعليم بالفشل مكتفينا بلقاء حاكم قندهار
توتر قد يصل درجه خطيره فكل الفصلين
يجمعان افراد موالين في حاله تصاعد الصراع
الى قتال يعقوب وحقاني محصناني في العاصمه
كابول والهما نفوذ في ولايات اخرى في حين
ان قاعده زعيم الحركه قندهار حيث نشات
حركه طالبان ليست هذه هي المره الاولى
التي تندلع فيها انقسامات داخل طالبان حول
قضايا من بينها حقوق المراه صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ذكرت في وقت سابق من هذا العامه ان
مهدي مجاهد وهو قيادي في طالبان قطع
العلاقات مع قياده الجماعه وقاد انتفاضه
في مسقط راسه منطقه سربول شماليه
افغانستان
نتج عن ذلك اسابيع من القتال العنيف حتى
تم القبض على مجاهد اثناء فراره الى ايران
وقتله فيما بعد
اتفاق عالمي اذن قرارات طالبان الاخيره
يقابله انقسام داخلي قد يعيد البلاد الى
المربع الاول مربع الحرب